Clearly, I am not the only one who enjoys shopping here.
Hema is one of the hottest retail destinations in China right now.
But what makes Hema so popular?
Well, Alibaba has effectively digitized the entire grocery shopping experience...
...and delivered it right to my mobile phone.
Now, I can get what I want anytime, delivered anywhere I want it...
...with just a few taps of the thumb.
And there are a ton of great features inside the store too...
...like the emphasis on fresh foods.
One of the reasons people like to go to Hema instead of ordering online...
...is to choose their own fresh foods.
This cabbage right here has a big number 3 on it for Wednesday,...
...which means it arrived at the store today.
And the same goes for this milk right here too.
When I get to Hema, I open the app and then off I go to fill my shopping cart.
If I have any questions at all about a product,...
...I just scan and see the full ingredient list...
...or I can see where it came from.